have you ever been cheated on and did
you take that person back
um i've been cheated on
and
i
it's complicated um i didn't necessarily
take them back but we had a child
together so we were living together
so we were together but not together in
the same house
if that makes sense so
yeah
but you know i eventually left but
yeah i've been cheated on
but it was a weird situation
but in that moment did you take her back
when she told you like did you let it go
or like no i do don't let it go no no
okay no no
not at all in any way shape or form how
did you find out
um i found out
from
so crazy i
i found out because i found a letter
in i was doing washing one day
and i was emptying pockets of um
you know as you do
and there was a letter in her dressing
gown and it was to this dude
and i was like
what
and um yeah it was
it was a revelation because we were
engaged
and um
yeah
it was crazy trust me how long was it
going on before you found out i think
probably about two years two years she
was having an affair for about two years
with this guy she never told you the
full story um
she never told me the full story no i
had to find out the full story
um so it was like yeah from then it's
just like there's nothing else to do
it's time to go
[Music]
yeah
i forgot to turn off the beauty
wow um
have i been cheated on
i have a like a speculation that i have
been but to my knowledge no no
confirmation
no but it's weird my
first relationship i was in
we broke up and then two months later
this person is getting married and i'm
like
so explain to me
you were cheating
and then
two months later he was engaged while he
was seeing you yeah i i put the puzzle
pieces together and i was like all right
[ __ ] happens charge it to the game yeah
but i broke up with him so it really
doesn't matter
maybe it could have been you like get
the aisle you didn't break up with me
how long were you together not the long
time
did you ever think about messaging the
girl
no because i could care less about him
not at all because that's never gonna
happen
yeah
[Music]
he called me on the way to a girl's
house
but i didn't i didn't take him back i
kind of cut off immediately hang on he
called you as he's and it was so
childish as he's about to go and cheat
on you yeah but it was like it was petty
because
i'ma [ __ ] this girl
is that what he did he was like he was
18. i was like 15
no 16 at the time
um and i wasn't willing to obviously
engage in sexual activities at the time
and then i think he called me like he
was pissed off i thought
nobody i was fifteen i did my mocks
oh you were young like you were young
yeah you you're doing your marks you
were young
and then i think he called me in like he
was trying to and i was like no i'm
focused on my mocks and then he went
elsewhere and i was like that's fine
like do your thing
and then
he i think tried to like
he was like oh let's be friends i was
like no like we're done and then he
tried to get back from after i was like
no like you actually called me on the
way and then wait he called me after he
left the girl's house and was like
you know
she was good
what did you say on podcast yeah you get
to i was like he was like you know like
i fingered her
like we did this with that and i was
like okay why is he telling me
can i just say i didn't ask my phone
it's like on my house phone my dad
answered passes me the phone and he's
like
okay cool i've left her house i fingered
her i did this i did that i'm like okay
like i'm trying to focus someone walks
like the mocs are you put it together i
mean weird wait what are mocks first of
all
okay mock exams
yeah
yeah what she said so i was just like
okay
um and then i was just done but i was
done with it because i was like do you
know who i am
so yeah i was done with it i didn't take
him back so outside of then have you
ever been cheated on you mentioned the
toxic acts which one is that the same
one oh it's a different one yeah but he
wasn't toxic because you know what she
did he physically cheated on me so i
i'll never assume that like it's not
even my concern the toxic one yeah yeah
i love how we keep saying that
yeah like i feel like emotionally he
probably like he did cheat like those
messages
but physically i have no proof okay yeah
okay
what about you
um
yeah definitely been cheated on
um i would say that was like my first
serious relationship it was like
but i was also really really young um so
he was a senior in high school
i was a sophomore
um so like
big it's a lot kind of a long story long
story short he is like uh from korea but
he's been studying and he has like
perfect english whatever but this girl
from korea came to come see him
i guess like for his graduation
and he's like oh no like it's just a
friend i'm like hey no it doesn't seem
like a friend if she's coming all the
way there from there to come to your
graduation like what is this and then
i'm like okay whatever i'll just let it
go believe him and then i'm like at this
volleyball tournament in san francisco
and my friend messaged me oh i see him
holding like hands with this girl
like oh like they're like very touchy
and everything i'm like no [ __ ] way
i call him no answer call this friend no
answer called him like 10 i like went
full on psycho i called him multiple
times and then like finally at the end
he was like yeah that happened i'm like
okay
cool
so did you break up with him after did
you take him back so i actually did
take him back okay but i would say like
why
i would think i was just like
crazy
but so like after i took him back though
i did break up with him after
which i mean you were crazy was that
like i think i was just like so like i
thought i was so like in love with him
right okay that everything like my
emotions just overcame like what is it
my like common sense right basically but
in the end i like thought about it
longer and then eventually like a month
later i broke up and like cut off all
contact with him
like no reasoning just completely cut
off right
was that the only time that's happened
yes
are you going to answer the question
yeah okay you know
why are you laughing because i know this
story and i love this this well i don't
know if the second one i don't love it
sorry no no i don't know if that one
counts though because we we weren't
actually together okay you know what i'm
saying all right i'll okay i guess i'll
oh gosh
this is the problem with people knowing
whom i'm so sorry um but okay what's
your real story then no it was um
i found something over the summer but i
didn't have actually like
it was more like
something he was like
gonna do
but didn't actually like do to my
knowledge but i feel like the planning
is like it's not full-on cheating but
it's like right it's a little bit of a
betrayal that's what that's exactly
that's exactly how i felt so he didn't
cheat he was planning on cheating
yeah and then i found out about it
before you done it
premeditated
um
cheers guys um let's just say he was
still logged in on something and i just
had like a feeling
so you went snooping
yeah i did okay
yeah
yeah because we we'd had like a really
big like fight
like two days before and i hadn't talked
to him in like two days so it was like
the i don't know and i was like what is
he doing
yeah and i was like
i think he's yeah so so then
yeah and then i like
kind of went crazy a little bit so
yeah details see when women say that
right oh one like crazy like what does
that mean i went crazy a little bit i
think it means that we do we like did
things that we
would never do if screaming and crying
like yeah did you smash anything did you
no no i didn't i don't i don't have that
in me no i just i just went like
i just felt like i went over like i just
went over there and just started like
screaming and like crying and just being
like what and then i got back from a day
later
i don't know in my head i like justified
it because he didn't actually like do it
that i know you know
that i know of so like in my head i was
like well he didn't actually like
like yeah like i don't know if he
actually was gonna do it and then like i
was like it could have just been like a
thought you know
i'm not saying like that was smart or
wise but that's just the way i thought
about it